taking charge of a collision that
shocked the country
the Central Bureau of Investigation is
tasked with finding any possible
criminal activity in the crash last
Friday they work discreetly they are
doing their job they work silently
members of CBI and the commission of
Railway safety are working in different
locations and everyone is doing their
own job and they are collecting evidence
an investigation by India's Royal
Authority is already underway a
preliminary report indicates a signaling
failure and the railway Minister has
blamed a technical problem
but the decision to involve the
country's top agency is being criticized
the opposition has accused the central
government of altering the investigation
to escape any blame for failings in rail
safety
the government is now spinning
conspiracy theories
and Shifting the focus away from safety
[Music]
to all kinds of conspiracy theories like
deliberate
interference
says it's an attempt to suppress the
truth
many of the victims of the train crash
were from the neighboring state and a
railway official is also raising
questions on an inquiry
we must be with the people
and we want that food must come out
prime minister Narendra Modi has
promised those found responsible for
failings will be severely punished
on the ground relatives are victims of
the crash are searching a medical
facility in bhubaneshwar that received
nearly 200 bodies
I identified my brother from the photos
but the police say another family
claimed the body and have taken it they
have taken a sample from a DNA test
more than 80 bodies remain unclaimed and
have been moved into deep freeze trucks
the cvr's role has been questioned by
critics the opposition and some even the
railway department they are accusing the
government of using it as a way to
divert attention from the real cause of
the disaster that they say is man-made
in bhubaneshwar eastern India